we turn now to this country's continued
failure to find a solution to the
rampage of gun violence here but now
city officials in san jose california
think they have found a novel solution
that can pass muster with the second
amendment and could be used as a
template across the country requiring
gun owners to buy liability insurance as
a way to push for the safer handling of
their weapons
we begin with breaking news own a gun in
san jose and you will need insurance in
the past 30 minutes the city passed a
first
of its kind nation gun law gun owners
will have to pay an annual fee and keep
liability insurance
so to learn more about this we're joined
now by the mayor of san jose sam licardo
mr mayor thank you so much for joining
us
how will this legislation work how it
will prevent gun violence
brian good to be with you there are two
components to this ordinance one would
require every gun owner to have
insurance just as any driver needs to
have insurance to drive in any state
the second
would require all gun owners in our city
to pay a small fee 25 annually
that would be paid to a non-profit
foundation
which would invest those dollars in gun
violence prevention strategies
evidence-based approaches
ranging from suicide prevention and
mental health uh to domestic violence
reduction and uh and gun safety classes
we think by making these strategic
investments particularly targeting
those residents who live in homes in
which a gun is owned and that's the best
way to get at the tremendous risk
involved in gun ownership in this
country
mayor licardo last may there was a
terrible shooting in san jose nine
people killed plus a 10th gunman would
this legislation in any way prevent that
from happening
well i can't pretend to know uh that we
could prevent a horrible tragedy
we know that no ordinance is going to
magically fall make a make a gun fall
out of the hands of a
of someone who is on a rampage who's
intent on causing mass harm like that
but we'd certainly like to have the
chance as if we could roll back the tape
a year or two years to be able to have
mental health services provided to
somebody who owns a gun who's clearly
having issues as this gunman in
particular
had palpable evidence of
very serious mental health issues that
his co-workers and in fact even the u.s
customs service observed you know this
is something that we don't have
resources for like most cities we don't
actually run the health departments in
our counties we'd love to be able to
have resources to invest in those kinds
of interventions mayor ricardo a
question for you from rhonda schwartz
rhonda
gun rights groups have said this is
absolutely preposterous idea and they're
promising to sue you mayor what do you
make of their reaction and how are you
going to go up against that
well the reaction is more or less what
we anticipated
we've had a lawsuit already
we know that to file a lawsuit in this
country
means exercising your seventh amendment
rights and you have to pay a fee at the
courthouse steps to file that complaint
similarly for
a newspaper to publish a story about
this event
many of those newspapers pay taxes and
that has been upheld uh by the supreme
court and the mere fact that it's a
constitutional right doesn't mean it
can't be regulated or there can't be a
fee that attaches the question is
whether we're creating barriers that are
too burdensome in the exercise of that
right i'm confident this is a very very
modest
fee and and certainly not going to
impair anyone from exercising the
constitutional rights in this country
you know we we certainly have a second
amendment that protects the right of
every american to own and possess a gun
but it doesn't require every taxpayer to
subsidize uh the exercise of that right
and right now that's exactly what we're
doing in california we're spending 1.4
billion dollars on the public cost of
responding to gun harm
mr mayor if you are successful here this
uphold is upheld by the courts this
could be a template for the rest of the
country
well we hope that other cities and
states will in fact engage in this kind
of
policy we want insurance companies to
get involved because we see how
effective that has been in reducing
deaths for example with regard to auto
accidents uh over five decades we've
seen eighty percent drop in auto related
fatalities because
people have been encouraged to buy cars
with analog brakes or or air bags and we
have
good driver safety discounts
you know through
utilizing uh
risk adjusted premiums insurance
companies can encourage safer behavior
and we need that in a country with four
and a half million children that live in
a home where a gun is kept
unlocked
and loaded and we know that gun safes
and trigger locks and gun safety classes
could go a long way to making those
homes much safer and preventing a lot of
harm
with so many guns in this country you're
up against a huge task in trying to get
gun safety laws passed
you're right
we have a country with more than 300
million guns and we're not going to
magically make
everyone safe with any ordinance or
statute what we're hoping is to make gun
ownership safer we're not going to take
guns away from anyone no one has to fear
a big bad government getting involved
here what we're trying to do is make
strategic investments with public money
that can resu reduce harm
and
encourage the private sector in the form
of insurance companies
to incentivize safer behavior all right
mayor sam ricardo san jose california
thank you so much for being with us here
this evening
it's great to be with you brian thank
you all right we asked the national
association of gun rights to have
someone appear here tonight with the
mayor but we did not hear back from them
well up next this week's winners and
losers two losers in the media
two very big losers
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box